i i stopped writing this movie about 20
times because i thought it was
impossible
i thought it wasn't gonna work i thought
no one would ever make this movie
but i kept coming back to it because i
knew if someone let me make this movie
that people would hear it and people
would see it it was
i allowed it to be my hobby i allowed it
to be the project that i would go to
instead of watching television that
would be the most fun thing i could do
with my time
it started with dreams and ideas and
things that were bubbling up from my
subconscious
and then at some point figuring
out going on this mission to figure out
what i was trying to tell myself
if you can predict what and where an
audience is gonna go
or what they think you're going to do
you can
use that momentum against them you know
i sat down and i would
smoke a little bit of weed and try
try and write a uh you know mind-bending
horror film my favorite genre
uh and at some point i just followed the
truth
if you're telling a story and you're not
bearing part of your soul or telling
your truth
i think that you're not you're not doing
that right
[Music]
that's in so many ways this movie is all
of you
all the parts of you uh being biracial
being in show business and
getting two different messages like the
best genre stuff this is an incredibly
autobiographical movie in a lot of ways
isn't it yeah and and
i think the the only way to
[Music]
you know i will ever attempt to create
anything again is to
be vulnerable with
my own emotions and it has to it
in some way it has to be
autobiographical
if you're telling a story and you're not
bearing part of your soul or telling
your truth
i think that you're you're not you're
not doing that right
as well certainly certainly that that's
the case for me
and um you know the i i
i i think when i when i in
invented that that party sequence that
was a
huge moment for me of saying you know
what these
these fears um justified
or not justified um
you know however they come these fears
of mine
uh i've never seen them portrayed
in film and um and
you know the the whole process of
figuring out what this movie was about
was about
digging deep and exploring my my
fears first and trusting
that if i got that across
that we're all human we're all
we're all made up of the the same
emotions and that you know and this is
what what you sort of finding in comedy
to in comedy as well
is if you put your truth out there
however specific it feels however much
you feel like this is just me no one
else is gonna relate to this no one no
one's gonna care
um that's not the case people are
people are drawn to truth
like magnets in in in art
i think um and and you can
you can see that i mean it's really
really easy to see
in comedy because when something feels
true
and when something rings true you get a
laugh and if it doesn't you don't
and it's just like it's just that simple
you know i was trying to
bring a piece of the conversation i'd
never seen put
on on film before i felt like there was
this void
in the way we talk about race especially
at the time
when i wrote it which was actually very
similar time to when we wrote
the the obama luther translator sketch
we felt like
racism was not being called out um
sufficiently enough for it you said
you're trying to tell your own truth
what is that well really my truth as a
black man you know that
my perspective that i haven't seen in
film before i haven't i haven't seen
that
represented um so like well in the party
scene
in get out for example there's it's a
scene where
uh you know it's a group he's the only
black guy
it's a bunch of older white people who
are trying to connect with him
with on on his blackness first and
saying things like you know i i i know
tiger
i think every minority has been in i
think i think i
i imagine you you know if you're a woman
in a room full of men you're viewed as a
woman
um before you're viewed as a human being
and it's those little
it's you know uh on the surface it's
it's a harmless thing
but what i i wanted to point out with
this film is that it's connected
to the the real the deep horror of
racism
you know comedy is where i'm from and
and uh the
the the the process of doing sketch
comedy
you know week after week on on key and
peel um
very much became about this idea of of
jujitsu of judo
you you if you can predict what and
where an audience is going to go or what
they think you're going to do
you can use that momentum against them
um so that you know all over this movie
i knew i wanted to have reveals i knew i
wanted to have
twists but most importantly
you know i figured them if an audience
thinks they know what's going on and
whether they like it or they don't
if you can show them that they've been
watching something completely different
the entire time
i think they have a respect and there's
a
there's a real intellectual catharsis
that comes with that
and and and and it's fulfilling for an
audience
so you know for there was a while i mean
the real big
one in this there's there's a few big
ones there's the rose reveal
which you know it was a very difficult
thing to hide
that rose was evil um
because you know it's like you look on
paper she's bringing him there
to expect an audience not to think that
is almost impossible so i had to kind of
direct
her and write that you know as if i was
it was a different movie as if it was
this love
story and to you know try and convince
the audience to just root for the two of
them to escape together
or to think at its worst something is
going to happen to one of them
and the other one that was
uh that was one of the most fun
reveals to protect in the writing of
this
how do you separate the crafting the
narrative
and building the drama versus the
integration of all these ideas
making social commentary that you're
talking about how many traffic is that
tag
a lot of drafts this oh you like started
this
five years ago you said right well no i
started longer i started
2008 i developed
the story for five years before i put
pen to paper and wrote the script
so for five years this was
a project that i felt like was
ambitious enough that there was a good
chance it would never get made
and and i thought ambitious in the
subject matter the idea of doing
a a thriller um
that explores the the victimization of
black people
um by starting with a scene that
basically is the scene we're used to
seeing with a black guy disappears
he's never heard from the rest of the
movie i mean that alone
is like a great idea so well and and and
a terrifying idea to write
because i you know again i thought no no
this isn't going to pass the smell test
for anyone
you know but every white person in this
movie
is evil you know that doesn't you can't
make that movie
you can't make a movie where a black man
kills a white family at the end in cold
blood and the
audience is rooting for him like that
movie doesn't get made
so i had internalized this idea and said
look
i i can't worry about this movie getting
made i have to write my favorite movie
that doesn't exist
and so that put me on this path of
working on this and it wasn't like
i was every night i was like for five
years
it was i allowed it to be my hobby
i allowed it to be the project that i
would go to instead of
watching television that would be the
most fun thing i could do with my time
and the whole purpose of it was to help
me get better as a writer because i just
i know that from key and peel when
you're when you're having fun writing
that's when you get like the east west
[ __ ] you know where it's just
it it works fun works and that's what i
that's kind of my advice to anybody
dealing any
writer or artist dealing with writer's
block which we all deal with and i
you know follow the fun follow
if if if you can't if you're not having
fun writing you're doing it wrong
shift up your tactic well so
you know the question is a great
question how
how much does hollywood the studio
um the producers it sort of interfere
with my vision
now my person i can speak from my
personal experience
um which is you know i made a cheap
movie
i made a movie for 4.5 million dollars
part of the reason part of part of the
reason that was a good fit for my first
movie
was because um you know that's
that's very little money in the film
industry
so because of that i knew i i had the
leverage to push
boundaries to push buttons to um
stand by my you know what the film was
meant to be for me um
you know when there were debates and
when there were
differing opinions of how something
should go
my strategy was not to was not to pop
off
the hard part i listened i i felt i feel
like
every note that somebody can give you um
has something of worth in it has
something of value
so if somebody tells me
hey don't you know you shouldn't have
this happen in the movie
because it's too violent
well i'm thinking well you're supposed
to be bi
what i what i don't do is go in and
change my movie and take out
the violence what i do do is ask myself
how can okay i hear that
so how can i put in something earlier
that makes that violence feel better
how can i make how can i bring this
person into
the perspective of the person who's
committing the violence enough that i
will never get that note again
from anybody so
i think it's important to
be respectful of people's opinions even
if they're they're
wrong there's there's some there's some
reason they're having that reaction
and then to engage in dialogue with them
and stand stand up for
what you know the film needs to be for
me these movies like the stepford wives
rosemary's baby
movies from the 60s 70s they had this
pace
and it's intelligence to them yeah where
you know you're you're headed towards
this crazy twist
right but you don't know what it is and
then when you get there it
it's it becomes obvious you've been
watching it the whole time right right
right i love those movies i love
i love i love the the the mind game
right those movies and and i think you
know people do
audiences like that i think they do too
i think people want to think
and i think you gave us a chance to do
that and figure it out as it goes along
oh well thank you hey you know i the way
i feel is like
if you start with how how it feels and
like i said you put
you know lakeith in the scene you can
you can be transformative like you can
make
um a movie where black people recognize
and feel
that feeling they that that we feel yeah
um on a day-to-day basis
and white people can come in and be like
oh oh that was offensive i'm feeling i'm
what just i'm feeling knowing that too
like that it made me uncomfortable made
me i get it
so to me that's like that that's why
a good movie a good story can can do
more
for for social change
and i think we need it right now more
than ever i'd like to know what is your
writing ritual or routine
um great question and thank you um for
that
um i you know i
i'll talk about the way this movie was
written because
it's it's the process i'm gonna try and
replicate as best i can but
as i was starting to say it it started
with dreams and ideas
and things that were bubbling up from my
subconscious
and then at some point figuring
out going on this mission to figure out
what i was trying to tell myself
um this this one was one that
i i started very early you know really
as a as looking at it as a producer as
well
and saying okay well this is you know
obviously
if this movie gets made i'm we're not
it's not going to be a huge budget
and um so let's mine
the the the things that work
that you don't require a huge budget
um that is you know so
that's why i put a lot of the the horror
and the scares in
the the dialogue in the performances
in the moments in the ideas because i
knew i wasn't gonna be able to do any
sort of
sweeping huge monsters or any kind of
thing like that
so it all kind of it was all very
this combination of strategy and and
gut inspiration and you need both
and it took a long time because it was
you know weaving these things together
i was doing scary movies
similar to doing comedy uh great
question i mean
they're both for me they're both about
truth if
you if you're not accessing something
that feels true
you're not doing it right and it uh
they also the technique of them you have
to be very
tuned into the audience and their their
emotion and that's why with both
um both forms the the technique is
tension building and release you know
when we're a teenager and all that and
we feel the most
isolated i did i you know
felt you know i had friends but still
felt kind of like an
alien or like someone who was
misunderstood the more and more i'd be
drawn
to stories that explore the power
of the other side the dark side
you know when i when i started writing
get out i was in a state
of great fear low in my life
and these projects have dug me out
of that darkness and so when you're
standing up the back of a cinema and you
watch an audience watching
get out or watching ass and you see them
leap with fear
is that a little moment where you feel
like god for that one brief second i can
tell you know i've i've
done you know comedy for you know over
15 years
and gotten some great laughs nothing
really compares to the feeling of
getting the audience to shudder
again there's a mischievous pleasure i
you you will see me in the theater laugh
if i get the audience on that level
there's a lot of therapy that goes into
this moment
there's a lot yeah and i don't know you
know something about it
is that i have less of an exact
science for wielding fear as i call it
it's more of the
an alchemy than comedy which became
almost mathematic at a certain point
nothing beats
hearing the audience be afraid and then
giggle afterward
i think this means so much because
writers know how
and hard it is to write something this
was a passion project it was something
that
i put my love into i put my soul into
so getting this from you means so much
i started writing it in 2008
and there was a lot of ups and downs i
had to
tell people you know people ask on what
are you writing what are you working on
i'd be like i'm writing this thing about
a black dude that goes to a white white
girlfriend's house and the parents
perform brain surgery on him and try and
swap heads
i'd give away instantly
and people would just look at me like
uh-huh okay you're losing your mind
i just want to say thank you and
everyone in this room that is a writer
keep taking chances take big risks put
your love into it
um it does pay off and it's the hardest
[ __ ] thing
and it can take a long time but our
voices really do matter thank you very
much
you